[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc this week at the round table of
dim lighting oh we got to I we just have
to share you can't even say amazing
experience that we had right off the bat
and then we're gonna get into resolving
some of your conflicts many of you have
these conflicts going these
disagreements arguments with loved ones
and friends and you can't settle them
and that's why you turn to us so we can
once and for all put this to bed the
prompt was what's the most ridiculous
disagreement you've ever had with
someone we want to help you figure out
who's right what we really mean is we
want to tell you who's right through the
power of conversation and verbal
processing and persuasion because you
can't defend yourself because we're just
going to speak into the ether and then
you have to deal with the consequences
the interne ether internet and by the
way all of everything that we do here is
either net based which is which is a
cool which is a cool fact he does not
know what that means of course need to
do I know is we're all Ethernet all the
time if you handed me an Ethernet cable
I could say that is an Ethernet cable
and I'll be like hold on that's the
crossover cable but if you put an
Ethernet cable up against somebody's
mouth and force them to breathe it they
will pass out but they won't be able to
tell you if it's an Ethernet cable or if
it's just like a simple phone line it's
all true you can't do that with smell
let's talk about this amazing experience
you know you want what do you what do we
want to relate it to you know I don't
like relating it back to like in this
new year we've resolved and I definitely
want to say the word resolution it is
this so maybe we just leave that out
maybe we don't need the context that
like we resolved to protect time for to
reclaim our lives to reclaim our
personal lives and even our
non-work-related
shared experiences as friends but just
to UM pump up
quality we're open up the quality 2018 I
literally tried to say up and that's why
I can't oh oh
pomp the quality Oh pomp to Jim because
no I think we should talk about that
because well I kind of did but 2017 was
so crazy and so many things converged we
work too hard
we got sick you know and I think we got
sick and tired we resolved a 20-18 we
would set aside some time for ourselves
well and what happened that I may be
building up too much already
was just validation what happened this
past Friday was validation that we made
the right decision and let me because
let me just say very quickly those of
you who follow me on Twitter shout out
to read him C on Twitter you already
know what other links going to talk
about because I already tweeted about it
but well I didn't know that you tweeted
ru instagrammed it well I didn't
Instagram it because I did have my phone
at the time I tweeted about the
experience and so I don't want you to
build it up too much because those of
those of you who got your head in the
game and following me on Twitter you
already know about this but now you can
know the context I'm sorry you walked
right into it link I had no plans to
shout out my own social media ever again
on this show at least today but you
walked right into it I mean I've already
talked about it on social media like
give the details I wouldn't say I walked
into it that would be like walking into
a wall I would be more like I stepped in
you step right in it man I definitely
have stepped in something you step right
in it and now I can't get it off now you
but now the cool thing about the stories
that we have two perspectives so I think
you should tell your perspective of it
first cuz you didn't know what I was
experiencing at the time that you saw
this yeah well and just one more thing
in terms of the premise of this is what
we went surfing and we two years ago
that we pieced together a good number of
months where we would go and I think we
talked about it here on your biscuits
about how we would go I'm gonna say
surfing but just between us paddle it
was a stand-up paddle surfing like
but don't tell anybody that like when
you repeat this story to somebody just
say serf and leave that part out just
say that Rhett link were sir sir okay
much cooler even though I the mechanics
of stand up paddleboarding does impact
the nature of the story too and I so
this is the first time we took we like
we didn't have a specific time we had to
be back at the office you just had to be
back home to pick up Shepherd from
school correct it's never happened I
mean and we drove we so we left a lot
later and then we came home a lot later
than we did whenever we we used to piece
together those surfing safaris that we
would do very early in the morning but
to create just how it conjures
creativity was just it's just so that
you just can't quantify it you know when
when everything you're doing is
associated with a deadline or an a
specific obligation maybe not in the
short-term but absolutely in the
long-term it just squelches creativity I
mean when every single creative thing
you're doing is associated like
one-to-one ratio with an obligation
that's trouble that's trouble for it for
an artiste
they call it unstructured creative time
because you never know that's what we
needed and there's just something about
just in general like getting into this
huge body of water the ocean they call
it called the ocean and just it gives
you this sense of perspective it gives
you the sense of altered life pacing you
know you without it's not logical but
there's an association with you feel the
tides baby you you know everything
slower everything is beyond your control
and you're just in it it's a very
healthy place to be philosophically
psychologically but not necessarily
physically because there's a lot of
bacteria in the Pacific Ocean outside of
Los Angeles rail right you should not
get in that Oh sick it is a sickening
place because of pollution but it's
beautiful at the same time
look too closely at the stuff floating
in so we're out there and it had been so
long since we had we had been I was
really shaky I wasn't doing well at all
I was like something must be wrong with
my board yeah I think it's the person on
the board and but even even then I was
having it just a great time
I mean and I look at we had been there
for a few minutes and I looked out
beyond the break and there's a there's a
dolphin there's two there's three a pod
oh my gosh there are that's a pod of six
dolphin swimming out there now this is
not the first time we've seen this but
odds are we'll see dolphin go by if you
go to that particular spot of a morning
I believe yeah but what will happen is
they'll just kind of they'll be going up
the coastline and they'll be gone but
then a few minutes later after you know
taken away for something I noticed that
I would see three know there was all six
again they're still all there and then
over there swimming around over the
course of our entire time out there they
were just around they were just around
and not scared at all like they swam
under us and around us it was well yeah
well I was I was paddling back out and I
see this what turned out to be the
perfect wave for our skill level in the
perfect place for us to catch but I was
I couldn't catch it because I was
paddling back out but Brett was out
there and I was like and it was by far
the biggest and it was big too but it
wasn't so big that no it was a it was it
was like or break your board and it was
like I've done before shoulder-high
which is a big way for us mm-hmm for our
skill level like I just think and a
Rhett's paddling into it I'm like dang
and then there was this regular surfer
who was paddling out and so he he was
paddling over the wave and then you were
coming this is my perspective of the
thing and I see you I'm like I'm I seen
my friend take the wave and it's like
it's a good place too because oh yeah
he's getting at least one of us has I'm
in the pocket in this moment he's in the
pocket
and he's riding the wave and it's just a
I had a great perspective on it and then
right after you went by this surfers
paddling over the wave right after it no
this it must have been the wave right
after it and I saw as he was paddling
into the wave as it and he goes over it
a dolphin jumped over the nose of his
surfboard and so I paddle out there I'm
like I was like man you got cut off by
the dolphin you know just make a little
little dolphin talk a little surf dog
surf dog surf dog joke there okay and
that's what I noticed and then the pod
was there and I was like paddling around
literally they were swimming underneath
my my board and I actually got afraid
that if I fell in one of them might want
to try to make babies with me because I
heard that they do that they do that
they're they've been known to do that
and that is not a made-up thing dolphin
rape is a real thing and I thought
somebody was joking about it when I
heard about I was like you shouldn't
joke about that kind of thing and the
guy was like no I'm not joking it's
seriously a serious thing and it is a
thing that has happened where divers
have been assaulted by dolphins it has
happened multiple times you don't have
to go do that google search if you don't
want to but it is a real issue
if you were not necessarily unfounded in
your fear
oh no I cuz I'd heard about this and if
you've ever seen me in a wetsuit yeah
well you know okay but let me tell you
my perspective on this because I catch
this wave that again I'm in the same
boat that you are that well no I'm a
little burning up but it wasn't boats
whether you do have big surf boards but
meaning that I'm rusty I'm back and I
don't feel completely comfortable on my
board your name is not rusty and then I
catch this wave and I caught it at the
last minute like turn my board around
and got right in the pocket and then as
soon as I know that I've caught the wave
and I'm comfortable and I'm like I'm
surfing
that's usually what I say right with
that my hey I look down and I see a dog
and surfing with me you know I ain't
direct headed in the same direction
surfing he was he or she was in the
pocket
as well just below the surface of my
board just surface of the water just to
the right of my board like I could have
pet the dolphin with my paddle right in
line with me just perfectly this like as
if to say we're surfing together he's
also sorry isn't this a wonderful
beautiful thing cowboy and I almost
almost fell the first thing that happens
when you see a huge because these things
are like eight feet long you see this
big grey thing and you think maybe shark
right but I've seen the dolphins around
so much that I didn't think that a lot
of times you'll think that but I was
just flabbergasted but she didn't fall
you teetered a sec i teetered for a
moment but then I can regain my
composure I rode the wave up it's like
and then me and the dolphin went and got
eggs benedict did you did you make eye
contact
I made blowhole contact oh gosh well
that only goes one way no I mean I look
my eyes made contact with the blowhole
right because that was what I could see
that's still pretty amazing it was
incredible highlight highlight a
highlight of 2018 118 so forth really
highlight of 2018 yeah I mean that is
awesome man I mean I I could I was
gaining just joy from watching you ride
the best wave of the day I didn't even
know there was a dolphin like you feel
to said I'm sorry for next to a dolphin
yeah then that would have made it I
should have remembered you know I wasn't
jealous when you told me about it I was
just glad to have been in the same water
I just felt you know you feel this you
just feel a connection with these
creatures man I'm sure the connection
with the ocean [ __ ] we could be for us
it just put it's just a I mean
everything they say about surfing like
you're bobbing in the water and
everything I've already said I think
it's highly recommended yeah well no
don't recommend it because then people
will start doing it and then it gets
more crowded than it's not fun for us
surfing sucks leave it at that yeah
that's why I agree that's why there's a
bunch of sea
surfing spots surfing on sucks and it's
dangerous and you will die
dolphins are known to do things that I
can't speak of and sharks you already
know about them mmm and there's nasty
stuff in the water stain and stingrays
say Oh a stingray a stingray okay we're
going to get to answering your question
solving these disputes but first we want
to remind you that you can still buy
what the book of mythicality yeah it's
not too late to get this thing this
thing does not have a celebration date
you know what I'm saying it's still
relevant and you know I think that if
you're new to what we're doing or for
some reason you did not familiarize
yourself with the book of mythicality
when we talked about it a bunch last
year this is kind of the definitive
guide to what this whole mythical world
is about the the content that we have
created for the friendship that we've
had for years is this this is the book
of mythicality the field guide
comprehensive man to curiosity
creativity and tomfoolery I was talking
to my dad on the phone yesterday
oh really and he said well you know I
texted you about finishing your book and
I just want to tell you that I did
finish it and it sure was good we should
get him to write down the but you do
that on the back of the but we should
rerelease the book and put that on the
back links dad said it was sure was he
sure was good and I just you know I
always got to get a little more
mythicality in my life too you got it he
was using the terminology yeah he was he
was loving in there he said he read it
in two sittings and I was thinking I
wonder when's the last time I dad had
read anything in two sittings I didn't I
don't consider my dad much of a reader
so I took it as a good compliment and
ironically I just gave him an anti
compliment yeah so for playing dad I'm
sure you're I'm sure you're an avid
reader people who don't normally read
the book of mythicality you can still
read it in two sittings cuz as my mom
said it's looked really great I like the
pictures
great now there's a lot of visual
elements to the book there's also a lot
of text I mean we tell that we tell the
story dad read it my mom looked at it
missionary links parents approve all
right guys you know we don't we want we
don't want you guys to be arguing we
want to start Cindy Murdock why not my
boyfriend and I had a terrible fight our
worst over when you should merge when
two lanes are being merged into one now
there's more to this I read it in a
second but just as a side note I
actually believe her when she says this
is our worst fight because sometimes the
worst fights are over the most frivolous
things because it's the fights not
really about the thing Cindy and her
boyfriend were in the car and they were
arguing a something had built up in one
or both of them and then it just all got
unleashed on when is the proper time to
murder that could be but sometimes think
you feel so definitively their worst
fight ever though if you feel real
strongly about something it can turn it
can really get out of hand real fast so
he said you drive to the front of the
line and merge at the last minute I
argued that you should merge as soon as
you can after seeing that the lanes are
merging I later read up on it and found
that the quote experts say he was right
I'm still not convinced I have a very
very very very strong opinion about this
so I you if you have a less strong
opinion or perspective just go for it
I I think that in general I am a wait to
the last second to merge but then
there's certain places on my route and
to work there's one place in particular
that I've learned that you've gotta
merge early and aggressively and you
can't wait late and be the jerk that I
normally am yeah so and I take the same
route so I know about this you speak of
so I don't but that's not really the
questions the question is not do but
your preferences I do Bo the question is
whether what's who what's right what's
the right thing
to the experts well it's interesting
because and I I'll just say simply I
think that the right thing to do is to
as soon as you know where you want to be
you need to go ahead and merge and
that's really as soon as people start
merging you shouldn't wait until the end
and merge and I do the things that I
think is wrong whenever possible because
I'm selfish and it's more important for
me to get where I well you're talking
about your personal behavior which I
completely agreement I'm just admitting
that I'm no I don't do what I think is
right no I see I have I have a very
specific opinion about this and that is
that what you your tendency to do and
also what her Sandy's boyfriend believes
is definitively correct so math was
supposed to merge at the last second
pass mathematically speaking what would
work the best would be if two lanes of
traffic went all the way to the one lane
and then right at the last minute you
went every other car yes that
mathematically efficient all efficiency
is taken into account that would be if
we could get into that rhythm in fact
the day this is what will prove this the
day that self-driving cars are exclusive
that's everything that's you know there
are no yeah people propelled cars that
is how it work people driven cars that
this tube they will come up to the lane
and then they would go one after another
because that will be what's the most
efficient thing just like when you're
exiting like a game like a football game
you go to a football game and
everybody's trying to get out of the
parking lot parking lot if two lanes of
traffic come together it's alternating
that's just the rule but the problem is
is that people do not abide by this rule
so a lot of people are nervous about
that moment of indecision at the very in
and they don't want to be the person who
gets caught with their pants down so to
speak at the end of the of the lane it's
just a personality based thing and so
75% of people just get into the one lane
as soon as they know that there's a
merge happening and because that happens
and that's always going to be the case
and so we all are just in self-driving
cars you see now you're just an
appendage when you go you're the jerk
when you go out to the end
then people don't let you in front of
them because they think that you cheated
right and you know what I 100% agree
we are both right and that that's why
when she did the research with the
experts that's what they said
but I do need to clarify something and
it's interesting because there's on our
commute there's two places there's one
where there's an exit that backs up so
it's you've got through traffic and then
you've got a lane where people are
backing up to exit off and then at
another point there's two lanes that
merge into one lane so when when two
lanes merge into one lane we're I I 100%
agree what I was talking about where I'm
I'm kind of I'm undermining my principle
here is is it exit is when is it when
it's a one lane exit and people are
starting to back up and instead of
getting in that line on the far right
and into exit line I keep going and then
at the last second I wait for someone
who's not quick on the gas and I just
pop over in front and if everyone did
that then the exit lane would serve no
purpose because you're actually in
creating on exit lane blow lane in a
free-flowing lane so yes it's wrong it's
a different that's a different thing I
don't it's a very danger the algorithm
works on that but I'm saying yeah it's
two lanes to one you should go to the
end but unless we get everybody by the
time we're able to get all of society to
agree to do the right thing will all be
in self-driving cars so it doesn't even
matter so your argument will be settled
by the robot Cindy like many arguments
will be I thought we just settled it
yeah and we're the robots for now what
which one do you want to hit next let's
do let's do these we got us a couple
here together okay about the plurals of
different words yeah so first from
Claudia swindler my house engaged in a
legendary borderline screaming match
over the plural of Bigfoot we were split
down the middle of Bigfoots or big feet
what
big what big feet is just a bunch of
large individual foots yeah we're in
agreement on this Bigfoot is the proper
name for that creature that does not
exist do we have to say that okay it
doesn't exist guys get off get out of
just forget it it doesn't he doesn't get
off get out of it it doesn't exist it
but it that mythical creature that you
are referring to is named Bigfoot so the
multiplier is Bigfoots
I thought big feet you can't change the
foot of a of a proper noun no feets
your defeat well I did this is an action
that acts I disagree with you and I
disagree with mrs. swindler here or
whoever in her family you don't know
what side she took I'm taking a third
side this thing is a triangle because
it's Bigfoot like there were 23 Bigfoot
gathered on my lawn okay I'm gonna agree
with you there if you're choosing
between Bigfoot's and big feet it's
Bigfoots but well you're right in
between two wrong answers yeah Bigfoot
is a problem with their house is that
they don't have all the information yeah
the swindler house is living in a yeah
he's living in a cave multiple Bigfoot
up there in those hills like you need to
buy that I mean not really there are
some people who think there's multiple
Bigfoot living up in them Hills
they're wrong definitively next one
Francis lover look LaRoque LaRoque what
is a single this is great what is a
single tums the heartburn relief
chewable called
I say it is called a tums but my wife
says it's called a tum passed me at um I
think it should be
pass me a tums I even tweeted it tums
and they just said it is called
heartburn relief what Tom's what I mean
Tom's replied and didn't even they're
not even using their brandy that just
means tums has a bad social media
manager dang because social media you
gotta give you know that fire your
social media getting some correspond
some win these business you know what
I'm saying you gotta you gotta lay it
down when you when somebody just leaves
your softball like that tums you got to
just knock it out of the park I'm glad
that you
is heart Boozer leaf we prefer to not
refer to our brand as the thing we
prefer to refer to our product in the
most generic sense possible and you
should do the same matter of fact just
by the drugstore version of our
heartburn relief medication because it's
just as good now I think I'm that was
the full I think maybe what tums is
saying having not seen the tweet I think
what tums is saying is that but these
are tums heartburn relief pills or
capsules or chewable this whatever this
comes is the brand tums is the brand for
the thing so tums isn't the thing that
you're chewing on tums is the brand
behind the thing that you're chewing on
which is a chewable but no one would say
pass me some chewable heartburn relief
pass me another chewable heartburn
relief baby so I thought this was a
ridiculous question but now I have five
minutes I'm not able to answer it oh
yeah I think they're good I think the
debate is incredible I think that tums
response was a missed opportunity
yeah but I have no idea because I don't
what did you say is there a family name
don't tell me what you think
just tell me what you would say right
now if you wanted one tums tablet from
the from the thing and I'm right here
next to it yeah I've never eaten just
one just say that right now they never
had just one that's their slogan one
tums but I just had one tums can't just
see I would never in a million years
have just one but I would also never in
a million years say Tom pass me a ton
because I'd have to make a decision to
change it to Tom because it just is tums
your wife had some tums up at when we
were in Big Bear and I needed some tums
and what did I said do you have any tums
and she was like I've got one would you
like and she said I got two kinds yeah
and she gave me those chewable ones so
it was the plural of tums what is that
tums
I've got tums I don't think so i I think
that please pass me at um I don't think
anybody I just don't think that holds
water I just don't
yeah tums is the brand-- tums is not I
think you some tums it's not it's not
the plural of the thing you're you're
eating for this heartburn relief I don't
know if that's true I think it is I
don't know I don't know either i think
it's hums hums to tom-toms yeah they
just brand it yeah right so comes is
Tom's is the brand's here therefore its
tums you pass me some tums they put
their name tums in front of every
product that they sell
pass me a tums and I think you just got
to say that if you just want one I'd ask
me a tums and unfortunately you just got
to throw the other way if you only
wanted one and they give you the bottle
or they give you more than one you got
to throw the other ones away or you got
to put it you say each hand a bag yep
say I actually only wanted one you said
pass me a tums
Pass me the tums pass me one of the tums
maybe you do a soft s you can barely hit
it do you have any tums because I'd like
one you know you got to really think
about it pass me a tums yeah I barely
hit the desk pass me at tums pass me a
tums what a what that means you only
want one what about this what about this
phone call situation here lo Andres
Smith hello rhett and Link love you guys
thank you we love you too I think I
really don't know you you're I'm sure
you're lovable I you're lovable and I do
love that you responded to us I may take
all that back after I read this question
though haven't read it yet my friend
called me from her work phone to
complain about her boyfriend and like
friends do they go about spilling the
tea to each other
her boss found out and charged her to
pay the call she called me again to let
me know that she feels I have to pay
half of the bill for the call she made
to me because I was also part of the
conversation
please help rhett and Link so she works
in a corporate environment she's calling
this is her this is easy to pay for half
of the bill well you think is easy
you're gonna say no she shouldn't pay
for right but shouldn't pay for half
unless
the beginning you say would you accept
yeah 50% of the charges but she didn't
know she would be charged for she didn't
know the thing is is that the person
that she called had did not initiate
this and was just being a good friend
mean you're just being a good friend and
letting somebody complain about their
boyfriend they then be charged for your
counsel you should be charging them
because it sounds like you were
counseling it must have been an
international or at least a
long-distance phone call to have a
specific charge associated with it must
it must have cost a lot of money this
feels like a ridiculous request well I
just think you know if you work in like
a corporate environment you're sitting
there calling long distance and it's
that's your because you're already in
risky territory on your own dime you
know this would cost a lot of money if
you're trying to save money well that
should come back but Clearlight you in
the bill if self old if somebody calls
you while you're at work and they are
complaining about something and you're
trying to be there for them and then
your boss finds out that you were on the
call for an extended period of time
and I don't even know what charge sure
to pay the call I think this may be an
ESL situation I'm not under percent sure
I think what that may be referring to is
she was charged for the time that the
call took not that she to pay for the no
I just think he left out the word for so
her boss found out in charge her to pay
for the call yeah but Internet you
really think it's international call
maybe it is I don't know but either way
no you're not respect you're not
responsible for this your friends
responsible for it when I mean but when
I worked for IBM I would print off all
types of stuff like I print off booklets
and reams of stuff that were personal in
nature that I cannot remember what they
are but like I don't know some sort of
lego loose leaf booklet you don't want
to get into you have talked before about
all the things I did at work like what
well now you have to what meaning I
didn't work I know it when I was working
as an engineer for the last year that I
was working there we didn't have any
work because of the whole like Enron
thing that happened way back in the day
and so I just surfed the web man I was
surfing the wave I'm surfing I had it I
had work to do
but it that's when I started to discover
like Napster and so I started
downloading a bunch of music who your
work cuz my work computer just to listen
to and then did you not understand turns
out that was immoral at IBM you were
doing that yeah that's not a good idea
and how in the world it was that was
wrong and I did figure it out I hope it
well it was it was right when I was
happy when people were saying you
shouldn't do that it was like okay I
figured out that I shouldn't be doing
that and that it was stealing and that
stealing from an artist and plus doing
it use a bad idea all around like you
could have gotten in but people got into
some serious trouble for that you could
have got an IBM into serious trouble
because you had we actually had a
situation we had a situation like that
here many years ago that's where I don't
remember who it was it was somebody who
no longer works for us yeah many years
like an intern or something but they had
one copyrighted music file on their
computer that was it had like the you
know the they can name the people know
whether or not something has been
illegally copied and it was just this
one file one song on her computer and we
got this letter from our Internet
company that said that someone has been
housing illegal music at this IP address
and we're going to disconnect your
internet it was like a big deal and
there's just one song but then it then
it was resolved but in in my defense I
will say that it was 1998 like I was
still a college student but I was
working at IBM and a co-op situation so
I spent one semester working there and
it was when we were just figuring that
stuff out so it wasn't it just wasn't
educated in in yeah I thought it was I
was doing it at home right and I saw I
just I was just like oh I treated it in
the way that ultimately you would start
to stream music like I was like oh I
just I'm just gonna listen to this while
I'm working what's the harm in that you
know I didn't really understand I became
educated in nature of it to it
thankfully not by getting in trouble
just by figuring it out and
and at a certain point we started using
this like crappy streaming thing you
could put on your on your browser
LimeWire and now streaming it was a it
was the first streaming radio and I'd
listen to like stuff I'd put my computer
on mute and then I would leave and after
like an hour of it being on mute it
would unmute some of those wrong on my
computer and it will start blasting and
my officemate
didn't know how to turn it off and he
got really upset with me yeah I would
have been too and he had we had to have
a conversation about that Cortney Koch
how many is in a baker's dozen
an alert team in Omaha Nebraska we heard
the Roasterie store owned by Kroger
called bakers I tried explaining a
baker's dozen is a universally known
measurement 4:13 instead of the standard
12 she whoever she's arguing with she
said baker's dozen was created by the
local grocery chain all right Courtney
or purse Courtney whoever you're talking
to is wrong you're right baker's dozen
is a universally known measurement 4:13
it was not created by Baker's owned by
Kroger in Omaha actually though and
ironically her baker's dozen the person
that we're disagreeing with is 12 hmm
because that does Baker Baker is the
proper name of the place so I think
baker's dozen is just a dozen it's like
Baker's at bay the order a does makers
dozen from Baker's you can say a baker's
baker's dozen you need to say a baker's
a baker's baker's dozen his 13 but a
baker's dozen is 12 at Baker's yeah you
could just say a baker's dozen from
Baker's
Brandon Jensen nope then that would be
12
baker's dozen from Baker's Stewart Oh
nope not if it's all about the
capitalization right are you using the
capitalization both times
brandy Jensen me and my husband had an
argument about whether lambs and sheep
were in the center for the same
I said lambs were baby sheep he said
lambs were a separate species
brandy your husband's wrong we don't
even have to Google this one but that's
the interesting thing is that they got
in this heated argument about it and
then at some point instead of googling
it the argument the fire gets stoked you
know cuz at a certain point in an
argument
you can't Google right if the argument
gets heated enough before you've googled
then you've reached the point of no
Google I don't think there's a point of
no Google I really don't but if you have
like the communication climate with your
friend or your your partner or whatever
where you like you like to argue then
you certainly have a point of no Google
because I actually wonder like you kind
of have like you and Jesse you both come
from a more from climates where having
friendly arguments or just having
arguments there's there's there's a fun
quotient to it whereas for me probably
debate for me yeah you call it a debate
and I call it conflict or an argument
and I like I tighten up inside and I
like I just want it to be over but
there's Pete and then we have friends
who but you love to argue would you go
anything I said yeah it's actually I
don't think I love to argue but you love
to talk about this kind of stuff and you
if you have a strong opinion yes I love
2-handed I love to have an opinion and I
like to be right but I don't like to
argue with people about it you just want
people to acquiesce yeah okay don't you
agree yeah let's skip to the chase where
you agree with me eventually
but I am curious what like the the the
ready nature of Google at hand how that
has impacted the the social interactions
of people who like to argue well I would
have thought it would have made a
question like this obsolete right like
why are they arguing about this I mean I
don't need to go to Google to know that
Lambs are baby sheep but Brandis husband
does and he should just go because it's
free I'm sure he's got an internet
connection she's got one she's on
Facebook asking questions however I
understand the desire to believe
lambs are different species because no
one likes the thought of eating a baby
and that's what you're doing when you're
eating lamb and so people are just
uncomfortable with that you know and so
it's just like no lambs not a baby sheep
that would be crazy
why would we do that lambs a different
species you know I think that's where
that the public misconception comes from
so don't Google that because it's gonna
mess up your life now what do you think
that people who like to argue just to
close the loop on that you think that
they what I'm saying is that they
intentionally don't Google that points
and arguments when they should Google
because they would rather disagree it's
not about the answer as much as the
journey for for those type of people
there's definitely people who are just
contrarians I know many of them yeah and
they just want to just disagree for the
sake of disagreeing because it's fun as
soon as they in fact they have the
ability to you know ascertain the the
rooms sort of mood or the rooms position
mm-hmm and they like to adopt the other
side
yeah and that's that's just a
personality thing and you can't you you
need people like that in your life
really because but not when it comes to
cold hard lamb facts right right that's
when it gets a bit annoying when it's
just like one you're playing devil's
advocate but are you the devil you know
it's like I start to feel that way it's
like but you be the devil's advocate but
don't be the devil only the devil thinks
that lamb and sheep is different
different species I feel like we're
making really good progress here we're
like we're getting in the heart of it oh
here's a here's a tough one
Danijela sure I feel like I should
protect the last name this is so juicy
okay just keep it Daniella in the first
letter of Daniella Heckman's
did I just say it like oh yeah that was
the full name that wasn't just a letter
Daniela ate okay that's better okay here
we go
perfect I'm actually right in the middle
of an argument slash disagreement with
my best friend and my sister I'd love to
hear your opinion on this one my
ex-boyfriend and I loved to go to the
sauna
and even after we split up we still met
up once a month to do exactly that our
breakup was mutual sir there is
absolutely no bad blood between the two
of us but for a couple of months now
I've started dating again mm-hmm
she means somebody new and it's getting
kind of serious so here's the thing my
new boyfriend would never ever ever ever
go to a sauna he is not into that kind
of thing and I really want to go
I've stopped going there with my ex
after I met my new boyfriend but
recently he my ex has asked me to go
with him again and I really want to say
yes my best friend and my sister
so I guess that's best friend slash
sister no the two friends in their life
one is their sister one is the best
friend say that this will be totally
wrong and I shouldn't do that I on the
other hand think that it's not or should
not be a big deal the breakup was mutual
we all we are only friends now who share
the same hobby of sonís all right and if
my new boyfriend doesn't want to go then
it's his problem if I go with someone
else right or am I wrong and this really
is a big deal you guys have been married
for a long time to your wives so you
have way more experience than I do
please help me settle this well first of
all I I'm gonna be very hesitant to make
a generalization that I mean I think
that you are wrong so I'll say that to
start okay so to start with a
generalization but no but you and
everyone else who does this is wrong got
that
no but the generalization I don't want
to make the generalization that you
can't have so because I feel like this
is I just I know this is your opinion
because we've talked about these kinds
of things before and I generally agree
with you but I also feel like don't
words in my mouth there are exceptions
to like I think in general it's a bad
idea to have lingering connections with
exes I just think that that's a in
general that's a bad idea but I think
the thing that well I believe there are
certain relationships where
I don't nature of that new relationship
in the nature of the old relationship is
that it's totally okay so I don't like
to just say that definitively to me it's
the specifics of this situation and I'll
I I want to hear what you have to think
about it before I get into I was cleric
of the specific that's what does it all
for me I would just clarify that having
carried on a friendship with your ex
when you're in another serious
relationship I wouldn't say I'm actually
hesitant at this point to say what that
it's just a blanket it's just a bad idea
I I will probably hedge a little bit and
say that's it you're in you're walking
on thin ice this is this is a dicey
situation
it's just how it feels to me right I'm
thinking because but but when it's
specifically about a sauna that's that's
the thing that's the thing for me well
you're like in a towel you also have to
think about the specifics of your
current partner right so if my current
partner was like I don't care if you go
to the sauna with your ex then it would
be the ball would be in my court but it
wouldn't be it didn't I have an internal
struggle or whatever but if my partner
says I'm not comfortable with you doing
that the case closed you just say okay
if this relationship means something to
you and they're uncomfortable with it
then you kind of have to think all right
this new relationships takes precedent
over this but well let me ask this at
this point all right do you agree that
when we talk about but it's not just
hanging out like I like I really like to
get this certain type of coffee that my
new partner hates but my ex partner
who's now my current friend really likes
this type of coffee and then my my
partner can't even stand the smell of
going into place you know it's on is
different because but that's an intimate
environment right it's yeah it's that
definitely so it's you know when you're
and maybe I'm projecting or it seems
like I would be projecting to say you
know if I was fresh off of of a
relationship and then in a new
relationship within like I'm talking
about like a year
and then you just never know when you're
when you're in this when you're in an
environment where there's lots of steam
and you're in nothing more than like a
towel and a bathing suit there coat
they're not how many of these are co-ed
I don't know it's sort of they're
talking it's a it's an environment of
it's a slippery slope of slipping back
into literally slippery yeah it's
literally slippy and you slippery and
you might fall into like an embrace but
then I drink it a naked embrace
relationally you know what that it just
seems to to me that when you old flame
man you fan the embers of an old flame
and it bursts into a firework I agree
with everything you're saying but I
think that Daniella H which stands for
Heckman's I think that there's so many
things wrong with the scenario you're
getting into the sensuality of the sauna
experience which I completely agree with
I wasn't even thinking that I'm gonna
add on that on to that and say the sauna
experience is not something that you
have to have a buddy for if you okay if
your ex-boyfriend was really good at
badminton and you loved badminton and
you couldn't find anybody was worth of
crap to play with and be like I really
love badminton I'm you can't play it by
yourself I gotta have a partner you'd
have a you'd have an argument but you're
talking about something like that's why
I don't think the coffee's a good
analogy but yeah you can also have a
better you can have coffee by yourself
you can go to a sauna by yourself you
can find somebody new to go to the sauna
you don't have to in you don't have to
have a partner to enjoy a sauna and so
not only do you not have to have a
partner second of all it is a sensual
experience in some ways I don't know
what kind of sauna this is but it sounds
like you're going together I don't know
how that works and then the third thing
is it sounds like your new boyfriend is
not gonna be cool with this which I
think that should be the ultimate thing
is like if you're new partners like that
makes me feel uncomfortable when you do
this thing with your your ex I mean I
think that's three strikes man but but
had to refresh my memory did did she say
what her she didn't any thinks about it
because I did not say that I think it
would the thing that would
is all okay is if the new boyfriend was
friends with your ex now that that
rarely happened right but that would
clear this whole thing up
what do they all go to the sauna
together I know the boy new for
boyfriend doesn't what do they just get
into a steamy room where they really
can't see each other too well and just
see what happens because that's like a
good idea no okay that was a bad idea I
just said the first thing that came to
my mind yeah you know what no one should
stumble no one should put themselves in
a situation see what happens
yeah Daniella I think you got it I think
you got a you got to get the new
boyfriend into the sauna which how does
he not like first of all that's the
thing I didn't even want to get into but
how do you not like the song of the song
is wonderful well it's hot in there and
visibility is limited this is a question
that was actually a Twitter moment from
a couple weeks ago that I have when I
saw this question I couldn't believe
that it was there was a debate about
this but yeah from the velvet hook on
Twitter how many holes does a straw have
it's infuriating we can't agree well
okay I got money I did not know this was
happening on the internet already so
right I have I don't think there is a
any debate about this I have my answer
and I'm gonna I got to make sure this in
the trap okay I got my answer do you
have you I haven't thought about it much
but I mean it's just let's just let's
get together countdown on 3 2 1 then we
say our answer 3 2 1 - yeah - holy -
there's one on each end
what yeah the middle of the Nicki
shaking her head okay here's why there's
two holes in a straw if I go to a field
and I see two holes in the field and
then and then you're like oh no no no no
that's just a culvert there's a culvert
which culvert is it just a pie a pipe in
the ground and so there's actually it's
actually just one hole in the field
because those are connected by a long
cylinder oh so you're saying you're
saying if I go out into
filled with no holes and I say you know
what I'm gonna do today I'm gonna dig a
hole and if you dig a hole across and it
becomes they come out I'm gonna dig down
and then I'm gonna come up somewhere
else when I'm done digging my hole and
you're gonna create another hole on the
surface when you come out the other side
well because the hole is the entrance to
another thing well it's not insurance to
disagree I have I've made one hole I
just came out at another spot you
started making a hole then as you kept
digging your hole became a tunnel you
may have not realized it and then by the
time you got to the end your tunnel
became a hole again the second hole the
second the hole is the opening the exit
of my tunnel that I didn't know I was
making it that orifice is another hole
but when you look at it a second hole a
macro perspective it I just dug a hole I
dug a hole but it has two holes on it
yeah no no no no it has two holes in it
do you dig a hole to a certain point but
if it comes out of the surface anywhere
else it becomes another hole well if it
yeah I dug a hole but I made another
hole as part of it and you tell me if
I'm agreeing with you or not but that
only relates to digging holes when it
comes to straws it has two holes what
I'm agreeing with you
I mean I think there's two I think Oh
hold on are you switching no the hole is
a transition from the non wholeness to
another the in the inside of the hole if
I just look down that the long the shaft
of a straw I will see one hole but then
if I turn it sideways I'm now aware that
there are two holes I mean it you know
right because if I take up the straw and
I let's say I've got a sheet of paper
right and I've got a straw and I want to
put each end of the straw through the
paper right how many holes do I have to
make in the paper for both ends of the
straw to come through how many holes do
I have to make in the paper to get the
straw to come through one two holes
no not if you're gonna just put a straw
to it through a paper if I want both
ends
the straw to go through the same side of
a paper two holes two holes and so
suddenly the straw part is not another
hole no it's another hole connected by a
straw
I don't do you have a succinct argument
Nikki because you're you're shaking your
head no there's no holes
oh that's a good point I agree with that
now it's a flat surface that's turned on
itself to me it's to make a cylinder but
there are no holes in the in the
material that made the straw if it were
made that way okay I don't disagree with
that either if you were if you had a
tube of plastic and you were making it
into but if it was one hole hole what
about if it was if you told me make a
one hold straw
I'd put something on one end to plug it
up I think I think you you're using
retin-a leti of digging the hole which I
was Ivan commandeered as there's only
one hole when you dig a hole in a yard
like if you're a gopher let's go you
would not believe how big a gopher is by
the way I straw tit yeah technically a
straw I mean if I was a very small
person that could get inside of a tunnel
it would a tunnel and a straw would be
indistinguishable if I was small enough
right all right the debate continues
this is why do I feel anger all of a
sudden I need to go surfing right now
Lee Amelia Ritchie says sell-by dates
versus expiration dates my boyfriend
refuses to consume eggs milk etc once
items reach the sell-by date where I
argue that the store has to sell it by
that date so that it means that there
are at least a few days allowed after
the sub I for home consumption I think
I'm right but I'm long given up I've
long given up and have to drink all the
milk on my own point of clarification
are you telling me that the date at the
top
of a gallon of milk says sell-by because
I don't I just look at the date no and I
assume well there this is this is
there's a lot of gray here because
there's best by dates and there's sell
by dates and then there's expiration
dates so I think an expiration date
which first of all is that not is that
not consistent across all milks I don't
know which one milk is I don't know if
milk has a has a Best Buy I think is
probably best by date and what's the
plural of milks is it milk is that is
that consistent across all milk
I think milk milk products you don't
know so a couple of things first of all
I didn't watch this but but Locke told
me about this my son told me about an
Adam ruins everything where he basically
ruins expiration dates and I don't know
the specifics of it but I just know that
that's a good reference but I think the
gist of it is that expiration dates
don't
no one knows definitively when things go
bad there's just sort of a rough science
that goes into every single thing and
they have to they have to put something
on there just by law but very
interesting this happened in my house
the other day my wife had some chicken
that she bought from the store mm-hmm
and it was still in its vacuum packed
you know packed up nice but it was raw
you know she bought raw chicken from the
refrigerated section put it in the car
brought it home it was in the car for
less than an hour you know ten minutes
whatever she puts in the refrigerator
she's planning on making something with
it but then our schedule got messed up
in six days passed and this raw chicken
is still in his vacuum packaging in the
refrigerator Ridge Mountain
and and then but this sell by date on
the chicken was two days from now in the
future in the future and but were six
days into having in the frigerator so
she makes some food with it and she says
you think this is okay I mean it was in
the packaging is in the fridge the whole
time it says the sell by day is two days
from now and of course I'm like of
course it's fine I mean people used to
eat chicken before refrigeration you
know I go
to doll that I'm like it's not a problem
but then I go on the internet I google
it made the mistake and basically what
can I ask why you googled it since you
were so because she said well that's not
what the internet says oh she had
already and so then but she said but I
agree with you and so I made it and
we're gonna eat it in ten minutes so you
just had to find out where what what
this internet information is but the
because that seems too if it was at the
store it would be in a refrigerator and
it would it could still be in that
refrigerator for two more days and you
could still sell it and that is what so
first of all so how on earth I saw so
many arguments about this and that was
one point that a lot of people made but
then the experts say that in that period
of time where it leaves the grocery
store shelf and then gets to your house
however long that wasn't she didn't
remember what she was doing when she
bought it how long it was okay at that
point the bacteria begins to grow
exponentially really really fast and
then once you get to the you know a
refrigerator doesn't kill any bacteria
just slows the growth of a bacteria so
if you've already grown bacteria to a
certain place you don't know if it
stayed cold you also don't know your
refrigerators situation it may not hold
its temperature as well as it may not be
up to the standards of the grocery store
and so all the experts online say one to
two days of raw chicken in a
refrigerator and then you gotta toss it
you got to freeze it cook it or toss it
and that seems so ridiculous to me now I
will say we ate the chicken and we all
were fine and but so the there's no
redemptive quality to actually the
cooking of the chicken would like to
redeem this whole exactly because that's
what doesn't that kill I said you just
cook this stuff in the the instant pot
and then you know she sauteed it then
she cooked it it was like a you know
Indian dish and so it was like cooked in
the stew she's like oh it's thoroughly
cooked that's not a question but then
the experts also said that there are
certain types of bacteria that are known
to grow on chicken that develop heat
resistant spores and it doesn't matter
even if you boil the chicken you
still get this particular bacteria and
it's nasty so it's very rare but yeah
apparently cooking it doesn't cooking
kills a number of things but there are
heat resistant sports and those are the
ones that really start developing in
that period where you take it off of the
of the shelf
so essentially the safest bet is a day
or two and then you gotta freeze cook or
toss it I bet you could buy like a light
to run the chicken under that would kill
that Spore well and then a lot of people
are like oh if it passes the smell test
but then the experts are like no you
cannot necessarily detect the bacteria
that would be bad for you like when you
say are you like your tongue out like a
commenter who's like I think it might be
smartass the USDA likes like somebody
there's some recommendation about it
some I don't know I'm not gonna it was
it was like a definitive like source
coming from food science people but I
feel like oh but then be waging on some
thread no it was like articles and then
people would engage on a thread and they
would link to that article but then
people be like that's bogus my
grandmother used to leave it in there
for two weeks or anybody who hunts knows
that you got to cook you leave the duck
and the refrigerator for a week to let
it let it age or whatever so I well the
duck and a chicken are not the ser ones
water fowl right but that isn't even the
question so the chicken on the water for
a week what's gonna happen the question
is whether or not that's by the
expiration date is any different and
honestly I guess there's a difference
but I think that ultimately it's all
rather bogus and it's just rough
guidelines so that people don't
constantly make themselves sick but I
think with milk especially if I think
milk you can't do the smell test if milk
doesn't smell nasty just drink it man
and don't go to the forums cuz yeah you
just want to go with it in closing
Bobby's sake Van Etten commented my
friend disagrees with me that when you
feel like you're gonna throw up and you
assume the position the smell of the
toilet water triggers you to throw up
debates on this at least once a year so
does Bobby sack even eat and think that
this is true or does the friend think
this is true let's say that Bobby
in other words who's wrong let's assume
that that that Bobby thinks that the
smell of the toilet water does not
trigger the vomiting now which would
make Bobby correct no I ain't depends on
your what's it already in the toilet I
don't want to so quickly dismiss this
because would you not agree that it is
possible that there is a Pavlovian
response to it can't that kind of thing
happen with any sort of behavior so if I
for many many years I'm going to the
bathroom and bending over in assuming
the position and then vomiting
she won't something as strong as my
sense of smell smelling exactly the same
thing in this case toilet water
couldn't that become a trigger I mean
surely that's it's all tied together I
mean it could but I don't think that's
what's happening I mean I think that
like when I eat that Trinidad Moruga
scorpion dink it and then I got off the
you know that night when I was in pain
and you texted me and said you felt
better because you had thrown up yeah
and then I was like I feel absolutely
horrible I cannot go all night like this
I have to make myself throw up well I
went up to the bathroom and I assumed
the position
and trust me I smelled everything that
was down there and I tried everything to
try to get it to come up and drying my
body did not want to let it up because
it knew it knew that like the it would
be really painful coming back back on
the return trip any woman out whew it
was a rhythm I could not tell have
thrown up in years assuming the position
in being over a toilet and like feeling
grossed out by a toilet certainly aids
in your ability to upchuck well seeing
so it's not
smell of the the water specifically
unless I think it's if you're grossed
out by putting your head down there
where your butt normally is I mean
that's gross man
let's just put it this way and you can
do Melling toilet water to your Vantage
smelling toilet water can't help you not
throw up that's true so in one sense
while I think it the the thing that
ultimately causes you to vomit I'm
guessing is whatever's causing you to
vomit you know the thing that's going on
yeah in your body and your body's
telling you to vomit it however there
are definitely external factors that
contribute to people vomiting namely
seeing someone else vomit
smelling vomit or just putting your head
where your butt normally goes and I
think there's probably an adaptive
advantage I think I don't know this is
complete conjecture but I would think
that the reason that you throw up when
you see somebody else throw up is
because at some point in the past there
was an adaptive advantage to going ahead
and getting rid of whatever you ate if
you saw someone else throw up because
chances are you both just ate the same
thing because we all lived in tribes and
we were probably probably all eating the
same thing so if it ain't working for
her I'm gonna get rid of it to just I'm
gonna go ahead and preemptively but so
there's there's definitely external
factors contribute to your tendency to
throw up and maybe if you've done if
you've assumed this position and you got
an especially specific I can't even tell
you what my toilet water - smells like
hummus it tastes like Barbara can tell
you what it tastes like
but is it so specific that it can cause
a Pavlovian response where you end up
vomiting just at the smell of it I think
it's possible I think it's possible but
unlikely you know what but you've
serendipitously disproven your statement
with a little slip of the tongue
you said Barbara can tell you what it
tastes like who has the most refined
sense of smell in your house Barbara and
who in their right mind if they had the
most refined sense of smell would get
water from the toilet if it's done I
think that well this is a horrible
analogy because refine is not the term I
would actually used because she also
licks her own butt and you know and
she'd lick my butt if I let her I'm sure
I mean she's a dog that's twisted so
ultimately but you're telling me you're
telling me you're one is your one
decision away from your dog licking your
body no I'm just trying to prove a point
to prove appointment no you you just she
doesn't have a refined sense she has a
developed sense of smell if it wouldn't
drink it
did your your dogs will eat their own
vomit it doesn't stink to them okay
yeah the jury's still out on that last
one thought exercise but I'm sorry that
we had to pair it with a mental image
I'm sorry that that's the thing you're
gonna take with you this week you know
what okay we should we should do that
again subject to what you guys think you
know we should do that again subject to
what you guys
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
you wanted that to happen again and ever
get two more questions solve more
disputes hopefully we didn't rile things
up in any relationships
hopefully we settled it
[Music]